[Applause]  for thousands of years  the ten rings  gave our family  legendary power  my son  now they call to you  i'm not who you think i am  marvel studios and the legend of the ten  rings rated pg-13  if i die it's your fault  september 3rd i know that you don't like  to talk about your life but a guy with a  freaking machete foreign arm just  chopped our butts in half  who are you  on september 3rd my father trained me to  be an assassin  you're such a badass thank you  marvel studios shanghai and the legend  of the ten rings ready pg-13 in theater  september 3rd  what happened to your shirt  all i ever wanted was a normal  the life rings  gave our family legendary power  show me you are strong enough to carry  them  i thought i could change my name  a new life  you can't outrun your destiny  i'm not afraid of you  studios shanghai and the legend of the  ten rings rating pg-13  you